[Music]
Elijah has changed over the years he's
given up we keep him heavily sedated but
there is a reason for that it's to spot
folder you won't be lonely anymore
we have two new friends the three of you
think you have extraordinary gifts like
something out of a comic book I've
developed an effective treatment for
this disorder the light will force a
different identity to take away from the
controls so you're not gonna shake my
hand and let me walk out of here
good for you what do you want I am here
to see if tales of the extraordinary
being are true when I meet the Beast
I very readily I need your abilities to
get us all out of here and show the
world we exist
that sounds like the bad guys teaming up
do you believe you are an avenging angel
I'm within just
I have to get out of here before he gets
out they are contained they always
underestimate the master line
it has become David I found someone will
require your full potential
you shouldn't be hiding in the shadows
you might want to try and stop us
a lot of people are going to die
now look like a PB and J sandwich
finally all of us together for the world
to see what we are capable of you need
to get out of here
what have you done all night
[Music]
you